warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised I'm supposed to start working
here today my name is
Haru welcome to
[Music]
the Pokémon means pocket monster or
having pocket sized demons as friends
there seems to be more than one of these
types of games that have a theme of
calling up or communicating with
demons the show is full of witches and
demons and even a genderbending
character people with flash and passion
to give all Pokémon pretty faces to
extend our arm to outer spaces Jesse
James Jessie
James listen to me kid when you get
involved with the opposite sex you're
only asking for trouble yes and that's
the kind of trouble I stay out of I am a
flaming moles I think that costume came
right out of his closet Pokémon go was
released in the US and became an instant
hit fans were running all over the towns
and cities trying to collect as many
pocket demons as possible this anime
nudged its fandom one step closer to
inviting demons into their physical
space not something you ever want to do
if you were a True Believer in the
spiritual
Realm
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
yeah